all right guys so I'm Ryan by the way
I'm Lauren I'm running super late for
work right now I'm running really late
there's this guy named tanner
then turian rules basically his sister
has an account and he's a big fan of the
channel and he would go to his sister's
account to watch our channel apparently
this guy he's currently in the hospital
right now going under treatment he has
brain cancer from what we hear it isn't
going so well so I thought it'd be cool
for the 100th video of this show yeah I
want to just dedicate a special little
video to him for you Tanner this is for
you tanner man and thank you for
supporting the channel buddy and I
thought like hey if I'm gonna say a
little shout-out and dedicate a video
why not bring a hot chick with me and so
I have this is for you so when you heal
up buddy she's gonna be waiting for you
she's ready to do things striptease no I
really hope everything does go well your
sister really cares about you a lot and
I promised her that I would actually
just mention you so yeah this is more
than a mention and since a lot of other
people couldn't be here Lauren was
awesome because I was like hey Lauren I
wanna do this video and she's just
showed up it was it was like no
hesitation she was like BAM Annie tanner
exactly anything for you Tanner don't
forget these words come on Lauren come
on
you gotta just you said six dates and
you boned the guy thirds we were
watching fifty-fifty the other day ah
you could do that too man use it in your
favor try to get laid as much as
possible to you that's like the that's
every man's goal I don't know that
sounds [ __ ] up - you're not buddy but
don't listen to any of his advice how
does that sound yeah except for boning
Lauren you should try that out it's
awesome trust me
this guy knows yes I do she's just a
pathological liar I know for sure it's
awesome best time in my life ain't that
right honey yeah because he was dreaming
oh I was wide awake and you were asleep
ass we would call that a word that is
illegal that we're not gonna say cuz
jokes like that are unnecessary although
I did hear something there is some
subscribe one subscriber I called me
he's like do give me a shout-out you
rapists Wow I don't know why you called
me a rapist I forgot why I brought that
up but I'm not a rapist I don't believe
in rape who believes in rape rapists
Nathan rapist born right okay should
have thought about that one before I
said it never had a rape conversation on
this channel so what a great tribute
this is your journey but then some other
rejects I wanted to give some input they
couldn't be here today so I put together
a little collection for you of clips of
them saying some stuff here you go
[Music]
[Music]
watching our channel and I'm so glad
that we make you laugh and that we make
you happy there's anything else you'd
like from us
I don't know I can send you like a
little autograph I don't know what you
want good yeah just let me know
um my twitter is at sally Lomonaco
actually think it's a salamander I don't
remember I don't even know my own
twitter name anyway I know it's a really
difficult
can't even begin to imagine what that's
like but if you ever need anything just
let me know I'm here to support you
because you support us make to
appreciate that yeah and just letting
you know I'm on vacation right now in
San Francisco it's the bridge you have
now been transported all right talk to
you later hey Tanner this is Kat Doss
from the real rejects I just wanted to
say that you're awesome thank you so
much for watching and we love you hey
Tanner this is V here to say thank you
for being such a great fan of the rail
rejects we are seriously lucky to have
you as a fan um keep fighting man keep
fighting you are strong you're powerful
you are victorious you are loved okay
we are praying for you you're in our
thoughts have a wonderful wonderful day
hey Tanner it is Gerry and Murray we
heard you like the show no seriously
that we just wanted to take a minute
here just to give you a little shout out
it's always weird to know that people
watch our little YouTube channel and and
you know thank you so much for watching
and for stealing your sister's YouTube
account apparently that's exciting
we're pulling for you we're sending you
all the good vibes and and and you know
good juju and whatnot and like GI Joe
that's how I'm picturing you like a
little bit younger though I don't know
how old you are but best of best of luck
huh see we love you and we're gonna keep
you in our prayers buddy
I just wanted to say I love you you were
here right now I would kiss you on your
forehead
I don't know if dinner would like that
very much and then Lauren would kiss you
on your lips should work her way down
Lauren come on I'm sorry man I'm trying
to help you out kids like very young you
don't know how old he is
so do it you know cool would be to fool
around with a significantly older chick
that would be that would be awesome
there's just one really hot redhead I
know her name is Jenny's what's up Jenny
I don't know if you're watching this
right now
she's sexy have you ever fantasized
about like a schoolteacher yeah yeah
yeah yeah we have a hot mom she's
watching she's watching she's watching
she watches all these videos your mom's
one of my biggest fans kernel game yeah
seriously I got really distracted for as
I can't there because there's these
really cool pictures behind the camera
all of those pictures of you doing
martial arts um dude I think that for
your gym here at dinner we should show
this picture so this is me Tanner doing
martial arts when I was a young kid look
how sexy I was look how sexy now let's
go lower oh look at that little chubby
boy doing the splits wouldn't you know
and BAM look I was so fast I turned into
a butterfly
yeah isn't that [ __ ] sweet see
sometimes he moves so quick that
multiples of you show up and then right
here
that's my demon fat Ryan witches which
has become my present-day life is gonna
say hi to you right now I Love You Man
Lauren show your [ __ ] face
[Music]
[Music]